[Musique]
françois mitterrand comme nous l'avons
déjà fait avant le 5 décembre je vais
vous poser des questions qui m'ont été
suggérée par les journaux de différentes
tendances auxquelles je le suis adressé
le journaliste étant uniquement comme il
se doit charger de servir
d'intermédiaire entre le lecteur ou si
vous préférez en l'occurrence les
lecteurs et vous je ne vous ai pas
rencontré personnellement depuis deux
semaines et je voudrais savoir et nous
aimerions tous avoir en particulier les
lecteurs de l'express
si vous êtes satisfait de la façon dont
se déroule la campagne électorale si
vous me parlez de conditions pratiques
par exemple la télévision au bar où j'en
suis satisfait on a été réduit au
silence pendant sept ans mais il faut
reconnaître que depuis un mois
ce n'est pas mal c'est même peut-être
trop pour la patience des
téléspectateurs et dirais-je à
l'exception de ces incidents qu'on
appelle technique
je n'ai pas eu à me plaindre de la
télévision pour ce qui concerne l'autre
candidat va le chef de l'état actuel ce
n'est pas le sujet sinon qu il a rempli
sa tâche comme il devait la remplir et
que joël polémique politique n'a dépassé
les limites que lui comme moi même nous
nous devons et nous devons au peuple et
je dois dire que je me félicite de la
grande tenue maintenir maintenu de tous
côtés pour la campagne présidentielle
cela valorise l'esprit civique
je pense que le général de gaulle ne ne
peut pas tout voir tout simplement sur
des détails lorsqu'il hier soir je
relève les erreurs nombreuses permanente
dans les citations et dans les
proportions le chiffre qu'il est mais je
n'accuse pas sa mauvaise foi j'ai dis
seulement qu'il est mal informé mais
comment voulez vous qu'ils soient bien
informés peut pas tout faire il peut pas
tout voir
c'est très difficile un chef d'état qui
veut te pour les pouvoirs d'arriver à
les maintenir dans ses mains la
démocratie c'est autre chose
la démocratie c'est le contrôler
précisément
c'est la possibilité d'obtenir le
conseil de plusieurs la délibération de
plusieurs mais si on concentre tout sur
un homme sur un homme qui a déjà rempli
beaucoup de responsabilités qui a le
droit d'en être quelquefois câblés alors
il peut plus rien contrôler tout
naturellement il propose à l'opinion
publique les dossiers qu'on lui glisse
sous la main qu'il ne peut pas examiner
c'est le grand danger de ce genre de
régime
c'est la toute puissance de gens qu'on
ne connaît pas c'est la toute puissance
du technocrate du fonctionnaire souvent
grande valeur p qui n'a pas de
responsabilité au regard du suffrage
universel et qui souvent appartient une
faction un parti un petit groupe qui
s'observe comme vous savez dans toutes
les cours des monarques où il ya souvent
des favoris circonstances donc je
n'incrimine aucunement le général de
gaulle lorsqu'il énonce des chiffres
inexacts
je pense seulement que pour la bonne
marche de l'état il faudrait que le
circuit ne soit pas fermé qui n'est pas
un homme tout seul comme cela isolés et
qui peut à la disposition de son
entourage il en va de même pour un
certain nombre d'opérations électorale
mais depuis quelques temps les ministres
sont répandus dans toute la province et
répondre en même temps les bruits du
fantaisiste
personnellement comme une confidence que
personnellement si j'avais certains de
ses ministres la j'éviterais de les
montrer j'aurais peur que l'homme fasse
du tort
et lorsque j'entends le ministre des
forces armées dire à cherbourg si
monsieur mitterrand est élu et est élu
on fermera l'arsenal de cherbourg
lorsque j'entends monsieur baumel
secrétaire général de l'ugt et leur dire
si l'on supprime la force de frappe il y
aura un service militaire de 28 mois
lorsque j'entends dire que novell
nationaliser la médecine absurdité
lorsqu'on vous dit que je vais réduire a
cuit à l'enseignement religieux comme si
je n'étais pas essentiellement partisans
de la liberté de conscience et si j'ai
une haute conception comme le mort de
l'enseignement public de la laïcité
cela suppose au point ne l'est pas le
respect de la conscience et spécialement
de
la conscience qu'on peut avoir dû
devenir comme de l'origine du monde
la conception spirituel qu'on a de
l'univers de ce point de vue tout est
clair l'état a des devoirs particuliers
à l'égard de son école mais de là à
prétendre qu'il veut briser l' échange
des libertés cela est encore une
tactique électorale d'assez ville à un
étage on est allé jusqu'à dire dans les
fluides lorraine sous la bouche de je ne
sais quelle obscure ce matin rue n est
que le voulait fermer les mines de
charbon
je ne vais pas faire ici la trop longue
liste des informations de ce niveau
seulement pour demander à l'opinion
publique de ne pas se laisser aller à
cette sorte de dégradation d'une
campagne présidentielle qui jusqu ici et
j'en remercie mes adversaires a toujours
su garder une route tenue est donnée de
notre pays je crois à travers le peuple
une certaine image dont le me félicite
alors voilà lorsque j'observe que cela
s'aggrave que le journal presque
officiel du parti officiel sous
l'autorité du général de gaulle diffuse
comme il vient de le faire depuis 48
heures un journal de circonstance à 14
millions d'exemplaires ce qui représente
d'une sait combien une centaine de
millions d'anciens francs uniquement
consacrée ou pour l'essentiel à répondre
les plus basses calomnies qui puisse me
concerne et alors j'ai dit tout de même
ça ce n'est pas général de gaulle ou si
général de gaulle y consent ou s'ils
l'approuvent alors - somme nous gardons
- entre nous nos adversaires le respect
de notre pays le respect de ce que nous
sommes tombés à ce niveau alors crayon
qu'au lendemain du 19 décembre
si jamais le candidat des républicains
n'étaient pas élus la faction
victorieuse de ce vent de la peur
qu'elle a eue alors je méprise tous ces
arguments mais j'ai le droit de
m'inquiéter
comme j'ai le droit de m'inquiéter
lorsque je vois les prolongements de
base à faire de police
lorsque je vois la sphère benbarka
prendre le tour qu'elle prend lorsqu'on
observe qu'en réalité on peut enlever en
plein paris sur notre sol de
personnalités étrangères avec les pires
complicité qui monte qui monte jusqu'à
quel degré hop répond s'inquiète de ce
qui entoure le ministre de l'intérieur
chargé de la sécurité publique
alors voilà je pense que le général de
gaulle ne peut pas tout savoir je pense
que le général de gaulle ne peut pas
tout dire je pense qu'il ne veut pas
tout contrôler mais je pense qu'il peut
se faire obéir
s'il en a désormais le temps nous avons
encore quatre jours devant nous les
observations se résume à ceci
rien n'est pire que le pouvoir personnel
parce que le pouvoir personnel est
toujours mal informés parce que le
pouvoir personnel ne peut pas concentrés
dans ses mains toute la connaissance
d'un pays et parce que le pouvoir
personnel c'est finalement un syndicat
d'intérêt anonymes qui se substitue au
pouvoir populaire
la dépêche du midi s'inquiète surtout du
sort réservé à certaines catégories de
français lourdement pénalisés par la
politique gaulliste notamment les petits
commerçants et des artisans
j'en ai aussi parlé il est certain que
les commerçants et les artisans se
trouve devant john de problèmes de
fiscalité affolante extraordinairement
compliquée mais je ne veux pas à
l'échelon nous sommes ce soir aborder
l'ensemble de ces problèmes qui sont
après tout les problèmes de majorité des
problèmes de gouvernement il est un
point cependant sur lequel candidat à la
présidence de la république doit
clairement sans gâcher c'est que les
commerçants et les artisans sont les
dernières catégories en france a échappé
à toute protection sociale une maladie
frappe le chef de famille où le chef
d'entreprise et il arrive très souvent
dans des milieux modestes celles harbin
on a commencé d'envisager une protection
sociale pour les agriculteurs y en a
bien fait et on n'est pas encore allé
assez loin
les commerçants et les artisans
je considère qu'une majorité de progrès
doit s'engager sur ce point françois
mitterrand l'express note avec un
certain étonnement que selon les
statistiques 53% des femmes ont voté
pour le général de gaulle et 21
seulement pour françois mitterrand qu'en
pensez vous d'abord je voudrais bien
savoir un peu ce que vaut cette
statistique est cependant je veux bien
m'interroger sur ce point pourquoi une
majorité de femmes votent rethel pour le
général de gaulle plutôt que pour le
candidat que je suis
il y aurait au moins une explication
voyez vous adonner honnêtement car nous
sommes là ici pour discuter en éliminant
tout préjugé tout parti pris tous ses
états il est vraisemblable que une
majorité de femmes croient encore même
si elle se trompe que la sécurité et du
côté du général de gaulle une femme
cherche la sécurité c'est bien normal
dans son foyer dans sa profession dans
la cité pour ses enfants pour son foyer
le travail du mari salaire de confort
morale intellectuelle ou spirituelle
elle s'inquiète du changement et portant
celle examiner de plus près les choses
les femmes qui restent à la maison ce
qu'il veut pas dire qu'elle ne travaille
pas comment sont-elles aujourd'hui aider
lorsqu'ils ont la charge de leurs
enfants
n'y at il pas un manque terrible de
crèches de garderie de tout ce qui
pourrait la débarrasser d'une charge
qu'elle aime et qui est quelquefois trop
lourde et la femme qui travaille quand
elle travaille
vous savez je l'ait déjà déclarés mais
il ne faut jamais l'oublier que les
femmes ou très difficilement accès à la
formation professionnelle et à
l'enseignement technique
les jeunes filles de l'agriculture
pratiquement ont leur barrent le chemin
de la formation professionnelle et les
filles dans les enseignements techniques
alors que les garçons sont déjà
embouteillé ont droit à la portion
congrue résultats comment voulez vous
qu'elle aspire un jour à un emploi si
elles n'ont pas de formation
et puis lorsqu'elles ont un travail
leurs salaires est il protégé
depuis 1958 l'écart entre les salaires
masculins et le salaire féminin
s'accroît au détriment évidemment des
femmes et la protection sociale et le
logement
savez vous dans quelle situation se
trouve les femmes au regard des hommes
dans la plupart des situations qu'elle
occupait pourtant il ya plus de
bacheliers en france que de bacheliers
toujours une situation diminué et pour
l'épanouissement de leur vie personnelle
songé qu'on continue de lait de traite
est toujours au regard d'une triste
fameuse loi de 1920 comme des criminels
lorsqu'elle décide d'organiser elle-même
ce que doit être leur famille c'est à
dire la naissance de leur enfant
yat-il sécurité pour une femme lorsque
physiologiquement moralement
sentimentalement et se trouve ainsi à la
merci du hasard le même manière ne
peut-on pas se poser le problème de la
sécurité pour les femmes
lorsqu'on examine comment se posent à
elle le problème de l'éducation
nationale ils sûrs et sécurité pour une
femme
lorsqu'il n'ya pas sécurité pour leurs
enfants les femmes les ouvriers les
femmes des paysans les femmes de la
bourgeoisie ou les classes moyennes qui
habite dans un chef lieu de canton qu'il
peut pas placer son enfant dans une
ville un peu lointaine qui ne trouvent
pas près d'elle l'école qui fournira
toutes les branches de l'enseignement à
l'heure en force
cela veut dire que cet enfant dès le
point de départ est prisonnier de la
situation de fortune de ses parents est
ce juste yat-il sécurité pour une mère
lorsqu'elle constate que seul enfant dès
le point de départ est frappé par la
justice sociale
faut-il aussi par les rats sécurité en
face de la bombe atomique
lorsque la france se place au regard de
la nécessité d'une force de frappe c'est
à dire la construction d'une force
militaire atomique
elle fait courir un danger
supplémentaire à la paix elle oblige le
monde entier à se surarmer nous mais
nous avons renoncé à signer des accords
sur l'arrêt des expériences nucléaires
que la russie et que la mairie consignés
et cependant l'atmosphère est pollué et
de grands savants déclare que cela
attentent à la vie des enfants des les
sources mêmes de la vie
ce sont les prix nobel qui déclare ci
ont consacré simplement le centième des
crédits destinés à la force de frappe
française
on pourrait peut-être gear convaincra le
cancer il ya donc du point de vue de
l'évolution de la santé publique la
sécurité apportée à la santé des enfants
dans leur évolution au moment même de
leur formation des garanties qu'ils sont
pas apportées par le gouvernement actuel
par le régime actuel
je ne vois nulle part la sécurité pour
les femmes ni dans l'emploi ni dans le
travail ni dans la protection sociale ni
dans le droit tout naturel à la
maternité ni non plus dans la sécurité
de leurs enfants alors je dis ce n'est
pas vrai cette proportion de 53 % ou
bien est exact il faudrait qu'elle
change dans l'intérêt de la femme aux
gars il faudrait admettre qu'il n'y
aurait pas suffisamment de formation
civique pour cette catégorie de citoyens
mais cela je n'y crois pas il pense que
la campagne présidentielle aura servi
parmi d'autres choses à accroître la
responsabilité de chacun et de chacune
d'entre vous le provençal françois
mitterrand veut savoir quel sera si vous
êtes élu votre attitude concernant
l'indemnisation des rapatriés et le
problème de la ministre ce sont deux
problèmes importants
en effet je pense que cela mérite
réponse pour la démonisation j'ai moi
même demandé que nos compatriotes
d'algérie puissent bénéficier avec
certaines modifications actualisée de ce
que l'on a fait en 14-18 39-45 pour ce
que l'on a appelé les dommages de guerre
il faut indemniser les biens immeubles
et les biens meubles et je suis navré de
voir de quelle manière le gouvernement a
manqué à son devoir à l'égard de ceux
qui pour des raisons politiques que nous
n'avons pas incriminer maintenant sont
revenus sur notre sol pas de problème là
dessus je suis d'ailleurs moi même
l'auteur d'un projet d'indemnisation aux
rapatriés d'afrique du nord et notamment
aux rapatriés d'algérie françois
mitterrand et l'amnistié
en ce qui concerne l'amnistié toute
l'information politique de l'opposition
toutes les formations politiques de la
gauche ont déposé des propositions de
loi d'amnistié
ces propositions diffèrent sans doute
mes rôles elles sont au moins d'accord
sur un point c'est qu'on n'a pas le
droit de substituer la notion d'
amnistie votée par la loi décidée par la
loi c'est-à-dire décidée par le peuple
et qui efface le passé et la peine elle
sourire de la peine subi avec ce qu'on
appelle la grâce amnistiante qui dépend
strictement de l'arbitraire du chef de
l'état
sur ce plan nous semble pour l'amnistié
c'est à dire qu'il s'agit là d'un grand
acte de volonté pour la réconciliation
nationale
c'est cette amnistie là que nous voulons
et je pense à cet égard parole du roi
charles vii lorsqu'il rentra à paris en
14 ans 36 nous décidons d'imposer
silence perpétuel à notre procureur et à
tous nos officiers
cela signifiait qu'il ne voulait pas
continuer une politique de revanche une
politique de vengeance pour des crimes
sont pour des délits politiques
ce que je dis doit être bien compris la
république que je pourrais être amené à
présider la majorité qui sortira du
suffrage universel dès le mois de
février seront et devront être très dur
contre toutes les tentatives de
subversion contre la loi mais nous n'en
sommes pas là je crois que notre devoir
est d'oublier dans le bon sens du terme
la division entre les français sans
oublier les causes que les ont produits
le figaro par intervenir de monsieur
kabylie se demande comment vous allez
arriver à concilier les apports kivu
sans annoncer dit temps de naître isorni
de monsieur soustelle de monsieur
georges bidault et également de monsieur
lecanu et puis de quelques autres sans
doute ce car je lis moi aussi avec
attention les journaux et j'observe
qu'il y a en effet beaucoup de
ralliement au candidat des républicains
pour le second tour de scrutin
je distingue respondents entre les noms
que vous avez cités car certains d'entre
eux représente à la fois une pensée
politique et un gros d'amis politiques
est le dernier d'entre eux
était lui-même candidat à la présidence
de la république pour les premiers et
bien que puis-je dire
je me suis exprimé clairement j'ai dit
quelles étaient mes options politiques
j'ai fait mes propositions aient changé
entre le premier et le second tour non
je suis fidèle à ce que j'ai dit je suis
le candidat de la gauche et à compter du
moment où je suis le seul candidat à
m'opposer contre le pouvoir personnel
j'appelle tous les républicains à bien
vouloir m'aider à gagner cette bataille
la détermination qui fait que certains
hommes politiques très éloigné de moi
les amène à me rejoindre en mettant un
bulletin dans l'urne en ma faveur
comment ce post elle si elle se pose sur
le plan de l'analyse politique alors il
faut que ce soit clair je ne modifie pas
un iota à ce que j'ai déjà dit qu'on me
demande de mettet finir selon mes
positions politiques c'est normal et
qu'on me demande de trier les bulletins
de vote
cela n'est pas mon affaire je suis
maintenant devant le peuple de france
engagée par mes propositions elles sont
claires elles sont loyales je le répète
le reste n'est pas mon affaire
pour ce qui concerne le candidat à la
présidence de la république il a
lui-même
aussi et à sa manière définissez
position politique et il lui appartient
au regard de la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes pas ce pouvoir personnel
qu'il a lui-même condamné de se
déterminer sa responsabilité lui
appartient elle lui appartient devant le
peuple tout entier
j'observerai avec sérénité tranquillité
d'esprit de quelle manière
tous les républicains quelle que soit
leur origine à compter du moment où ils
aiment la république et la démocratie
voudront bien comprendre que la victoire
pour la démocratie véritable dépens et
pour beaucoup de leur adhésion à ma
candidature
l'aurore voudrais savoir qu'elle entend
tout quel contrat vous avez passé avec
les codes des listes
et bien faut-il me répéter au début de
septembre
j'ai dit voilà ce que je pense des
institutions voilà ce que je pense de la
défense des libertés menacées
voilà ce que je pense de la politique
extérieure et en particulier de l'europe
voilà ce que je pense de la défense
militaire et en particulier de la force
de frappe
voilà ce que je pense de la politique
économique en m'attachant spécialement
au cinquième plan voilà ce que je pense
de la politique sociale et enfin voilà
ce que je veux pour l'éducation
nationale c'est clair je me suis défini
librement l'information politique toute
la gauche et une partie du centre gauche
une partie du centre et tout court qui
me soutiennent aujourd'hui ce sont
déterminer librement y compris le parti
comme eni soit là le contrat c'est un
contrat moral un contrat politique
un contrat que j'ai d'ailleurs à l'égard
de tous les citoyens de toutes les
femmes de tous les hommes qui ont voté
pour moi dès le premier tour de scrutin
c'est encore un contrat que je souscris
à l'égard de tous ceux qui s'apprêtent à
me soutenir
tout cela est si clair il convient je le
pense de n'ajouter que quelques mots
alors je suppose que la question du
journal l'aurore ville peut-être plus
l'avenir que le passé en effet au
lendemain du 19 des 115 viendra-t-il et
bien élu président de la république je
me comporterai c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela que je suis candidat comme un
républicain scrupuleux des lois et des
usages d'une république démocratique
puisque je dissoudre l assemblée
nationale puisqu'il y aura de nouvelles
élections législatives cela signifie que
toutes les formations politiques
pourront s'adresser librement au peuple
pour obtenir cela ce sentiment est le
cas c'est chiant pour faire une majorité
comment sera composée cette majorité
bien sans doute le courant populaire qui
m'ont rapporté la présidence de la
république
aura-t-il quelques chances de se
prolonger dans le temps ceci n'est pas
une affaire de préférence personnelle je
constaterai ce que sera la majorité
issue
suffrage universel et il appartiendra
aux formations politiques responsables
de se déterminer
elle main voilà ce qui se passera si je
suis élu président de la république
paris normandie françois mitterrand
demandent si le président de la
république doit être élu en même temps
que l'assemblée nationale et pour la
même durée que cette assemblée nationale
je répondrai brièvement en indiquant qu
on ne peut pas lier exactement le sort
du président de la république et celui
de l'assemblée nationale
car lorsque président de la république
est amené à dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale c'est un droit que lui confère
la constitution
personne ne comprendrait que il
démissionne en même temps mais dans
cette question de paris normandie je
relève une suggestion intéressante
je crois en effet qu'un président de la
république élu au suffrage universel
devrait avoir un mandat moins long
sept ans c'est trop personnellement je
serais partisan de 5
en effet il faut que le président de la
république ne succombent à la tentation
qu'on a vu pratiquement fleurir sur le
ring gaulliste c'est à dire la tentation
du pouvoir personnel
pour cela un mandat réduit me paraît
nécessaire il me reste encore françois
mitterrand une série de questions que le
temps m'oblige à rassembler c'est encore
paris normandie qui s'intéresse ce
regroupement politique
ces combats qui s'intéressent à la
composition du gouvernement de gestion
dont vous avez déjà parlé c'est le monde
qui s'inquiètent du temps qui passera
entre l'élection du président et
l'élection de la nouvelle chambre quand
on siffle je crois que tous ces journaux
pose en fait le problème de la stabilité
politique et il faut bien poser cette
question car elle déterminera le choix
le grand nombre de citoyens la stabilité
politique à mes yeux tient à quatre
conditions
la première c'est le regroupement de nos
formations politiques la réforme de nos
structures partisanes bien je crois
qu'on est sur le bon chemin
en fait 4 famille politique se dessine
la famille communiste la famille
démocrate socialiste
la famille démocrate libéral et la
famille conservatrice
l'un des grands dangers de l'ancien
démocratie c'est et la diversité des
petites formations
en cause réelle d'instabilité la
deuxième condition qui est aux
institutions mais les institutions bien
nous les avons ce sont les moeurs dont
disposera le général de gaulle au mois à
la différence près que le général de
gaulle ne les appliquent pas lui
pourtant qui les a proposés à 18
millions de français en fait 18 millions
de français qui les ont votés en 1958 et
que moi soucieux de la loi je les
appliquerait et ses institutions ont le
mérite
elles ont des dépôts mais pas celui là
ces institutions le mérite d'établir un
équilibre entre le pouvoir exécutif et
le pouvoir législatif
troisième condition il faut une majorité
or il n'y a plus de majorité politique
en france parce que la politique de la
majorité a été condamné d'abord elle a
été condamnée au premier tour de scrutin
[Musique]